good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3125
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
scp-3125 is kept inside cognitohazard
containment unit 3125 on the first floor
of site 41. this containment unit is a
10 by 15 by 3 meter cuboidal room clad
in layers of lead soundproofing and
telepathic shielding
access is through an airlock system at
one end of the containment unit this
airlock is programmed to allow only one
person to enter the containment unit at
a time and to remain locked until this
person exits before allowing another
person to enter
under no circumstances may any coherent
information be allowed to leave the
containment unit this includes written
and electronic notes photographs audio
and video recordings sound
electromagnetic and particle-based
signals and psi emanations during the
exit cycle a purge system rigged to the
airlock flushes the occupant's memory by
flooding the airlock with amnestic gas
for three minutes
a senior anti-mimetics division staff
member must visit scp-3125
every six weeks or 42 days
end of
file input numerical passcode
accept it applying anti-memetic counter
measures
standby
item number scp-3125
object class
header
special containment procedures
scp-3125 is subject to inverted
containment protocols and is present
everywhere in reality except for those
places which have been specifically
purged of its influence the interior of
cognitohazard containment unit 3125 on
site 41 where this document resides is
the only location in the world to have
been successfully purged in this way
this containment unit is a 10 by 15 by 3
meter cuboidal room clad in layers of
lead sound proofing material and
telepathic shielding axis is through an
airlock system at one end of the
containment unit this airlock is
programmed to allow only one person to
enter the containment unit at a time
and to remain locked until this person
exits before allowing another person to
enter
under no circumstances may any coherent
information be allowed to leave the
containment unit this includes written
and electronic notes photographs audio
and video recordings sound
electromagnetic and particle-based
signals and psi emanations a purge
system rigged to the airlock flushes the
occupant's memory by flooding the
airlock with amnestic gas for three
minutes during the exit cycle
an alternate scp entry must be
maintained in the main foundation
database giving only technical
specifications of the containment unit
provisions for senior anti-mimetics
division staff to visit the unit's
interior on a regular basis and no
description
description
scp-3125 is an extremely large
c full theta dimensional fractal
topology attachment 13 highly aggressive
anomalous metastasized meme complex
originating externally to our reality
and now partially intersecting it
scp-3125 is adapted for survival in an
idiotic ecology considerably more
violent and hostile than our own here
our own refers to human head space the
set of all ideas which humans have
or are biologically capable of having
because humans have no natural exposure
to ideas as aggressive as scp-3125
human minds have no protective
evolutionary adaptations against it
individuals possessed of scp-3125
become incapable of entertaining weaker
conventional ideas and become instead
wholly bodily subordinate to the purpose
of serving and disseminating the core
concepts of scp-3125
in addition although undergoing no
outwardly visible physical alteration
they cease to be externally recognizable
as human
scp-3125 is not yet entirely present in
our reality
upon its arrival the highly
interconnected nature of human knowledge
exchange systems means that it will take
no longer than 12 hours possibly as few
as four hours to encompass dominate and
replace all human thought at this point
humanity as an abstract concept
along with all attendant abstracts such
as civilization culture society
community and family will have ceased to
exist the foundation terms such an
eventuality and mk-class
end-of-the-world scenario
the foundation possesses numerous proven
techniques for arresting the spread of
such aggressive idea complexes but these
are all rendered unworkable in practice
by scp-3125's
autonomic defense response or boundary
layer fully assembling a mental picture
of scp-3125
and perceiving its true shape causes
scp-3125 in turn to be able to perceive
the observer it then attacks the
observer killing them the mechanism of
the attack is unclear but appears to be
at least partially physical mental
bystanders
individuals whose thoughts and ideas
resemble those of the observer are also
attacked this invariably includes the
observer's entire extended research
group and often their close family
parents and offspring
the attack has the net effect of erasing
all knowledge both of scp-3125
and its attack from the world this
informational numbing effect performs a
similar function to the anesthetic
saliva of a mosquito's bite enabling
scp-31
to evade detection prior to its full
incarnation
foundation staff discovering
scp-3125 may be able to escape its
attack via prompt use of amnestic
medication to erase their knowledge of
it
in either case the net result is that
the interior of a suitably shielded
containment unit is the only location
where it is safe to observe record or
even acknowledge the existence of
scp-3120
outside of a containment unit a true
written description of scp-3125
would constitute a lethal cognito hazard
scp-3125 could be effectively
neutralized using a machine proposed by
the late dr bartholomew hughes called an
aeriality amplifier see schematics
attachment 129 however as well as
requiring tremendous material resources
this machine could not be constructed
without its builders understanding why
it was being built which would require
understanding of scp-3125
which would prove fatal to the project
no means of neutralizing scp-3125
using only the resources in this room is
known
history
due to the described defense mechanism
scp-3125's observation history is almost
entirely missing in particular it is
unclear exactly how this containment
unit came to be built and how these
containment procedures were established
much data has been accrued in this
containment unit over the course of
successive visits by foundation
researchers this data was brought from
the outside in the hope of being useful
and left here in accordance with the
containment procedures in addition to
this database entry the reader will find
multiple electronic copies of the
foundation database academic data sets
of all kinds and extensive public news
archives
as is to be expected much of this data
is not germane to the topic of
containing scp-3125
nevertheless correlation and analysis by
successive visitors has allowed the
following facts to emerge
although
scp-3125 is not yet fully present in our
reality its indirect effects and
foreshocks for example scp
scp
scp
and scp
are easily discovered by any
well-equipped mimetics research project
mimetics research is today a much
diminished science from what it was at
its peak in mid-2008 there existed more
than 400 institutions pursuing research
likely to uncover scp-3125
including government agencies military
branches private corporations
independent laboratories
university research projects and notable
amateur groups
many of these were groups of interests
or internal divisions within groups of
interest none of these groups still
exist except for the foundation's
anti-medics division
almost nobody in the world is
consciously aware of this decline and
explanations for the disappearance of
these groups have not been forthcoming
simple deduction gives that all of these
groups eventually discovered scp-3125
and were consumed by it and that this is
in fact the inevitable fate of all
competent memetics research
the
division's persistence is attributed to
its specialist training and its ready
access to reliable amnestic medication
despite this the division two has shrunk
considerably in recent years from a
reported staff of well over 4 000 people
in 2012 to as of september 2015 125
this figure is on track to reach zero
before the end of 2015. over the same
period the division's physical worldwide
presence has similarly shrunk from a
network of sites and smaller outposts on
every continent to this single site
site-41 in particular the division's
headquarters at site 167 are now missing
from the division's collective memory
and presumed neutralized by
scp-3125's concealment response
addendum
further analysis of the available data
specifically architectural diagrams of
site-41 attachment 38 indicates the
existence of a second containment unit
on site 41 conforming to the same basic
design philosophy as this one this
second unit s041 b3000
was built 210 meters below ground level
it features identical broad spectrum
informational cladding but has more than
one thousand times the volume of
cognitohazard containment unit 3125
along with an amnestic airlock large
enough to ingest a 20-foot equivalent
shipping container
information relating to the date of
construction and purpose of s041
b-3000 is absent from foundation records
and is presumed to have been
deliberately erased the unit itself is
hermetically sealed and has been for an
indeterminate period of time
regardless of
s041b3000s in intended purpose it like
any such containment unit is capable of
acting as a shelter from scp-3125
addendum 2
and the rest hopefully is blindingly
obvious
s041b3000 was originally constructed to
house a long-term project to construct
hugh's irreality amplifier while that's
been going on the rest of us have been
fighting an unconscious war in order to
buy time we have been losing but losing
as slowly as humanly possible
the time we have bought is now up it's
an extremely bad sign that nobody inside
s041b3000 has broken the seal yet but
there is no ground left for us to seat
and there are no more bodies to throw
into
scp-3125's maw to slow it down
va is here
ready or not
i'm going to go to s041
and use the machine i think i can get
the information out through the airlock
i think i can get to the vault alive
this was the plan it's become garbled in
the retelling because of variables but i
know that this was my plan because i
know myself
what else could it have been
standard procedure is that i have to
tell you what to do next if this doesn't
work that's the asynchronous research
covenant but i don't have a good picture
of who you can even be
reading this and alive in your scenario
there is no machine fuse is missing i'm
dead the site is ruined and how do you
even get in here can you be the
foundation are you conscious is there a
single word of this you comprehend
you live in a world bathed with a cp
3125 that's the lost condition
i can't help someone who doesn't exist
martin wheeler chief of anti-medics
november 30th 2015.
addendum 3.
i found your body
and finding your body was a powerful
disorientating sensation for me i don't
mind admitting i used to know a martin
during the brief period in which i knew
him he wasn't one to admit defeat as
easily as you still that was a long time
ago
far be it for me to tell you your
business but i fear you missed a trick
from the evidence i can see this was
never the only anti-mimetics division
site there were others i imagine they're
now all effectively invisible to most
pastors by of course just like this one
but i presume that they just like this
one still physically exist your plan i
think was in place for longer than you
know and since you weren't at liberty to
retain its details you put it into
action more than once
there is another vault fitting the
description truck size domestic airlock
and all s one sixty seven zero zero one
sixty one eighty three
site 167 is a non-entity of course which
is most likely why you missed it it's
likely ruined and it's quite definitely
a long god damn way from here on foot
but still i think it's better than have
a chance
i could die in this boondoggle too
naturally as the world has become
something of a horror show of light in
any case i can trust that anyone
following in my footsteps and reading
these additional words will have the
presence of mind to pursue the same
basic strategy
still existing and despite everything
adam wheeler interloper
may 4th 2017.
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zolfax 99
ian j allsup
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmuy
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
african submarine vore
amir sabhan
sivanity
kristoff kozak zlezak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky
aqua pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbage
longinus
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you